[Musica]
ingegneria
parafrasando il titolo di un film dei
fratelli cohen potremmo dire non è un
paese per donne
in realtà negli oltre venti anni della
mia esperienza professionale in questo
campo quello dell'ingegneria il numero
delle donne è aumentato prevalentemente
perché sono aumentate le laureate di
pari passo che aumentava il numero delle
donne
ho visto cambiare negli ambienti di
lavoro le abitudini delle piccole
abitudini
gli ingegneri hanno iniziato ad arrivare
a lavorare più eleganti più puliti e
questo più rilassati e soprattutto
finalmente sono scomparsi quei regali
che vicino a natale arrivano sempre nei
nostri studi ovvero i calendari con le
donne nude per cui siamo iniziati bene
questo mix ha iniziato a produrre buoni
risultati ma tutti noi credo che
quotidianamente
vediamo le differenze tra uomini e donne
nei comportamenti di tutti i giorni e
nelle sfide che ci si presentano
pensavo che questo fosse semplicemente
frutto della mia esperienza ma in realtà
ho trovato una giustificazione
scientifica
a tutto ciò ho trovato uno studio di uno
americano che spiega che le differenze
tra uomini e donne risiedono in un
differente modo di comunicare tra loro
dei due emisferi cerebrali negli uomini
questo modo di comunicare aumenta e
migliora le abilità spaziali e motorie
nelle donne c'è una connessione generale
globale più completa
questo fa sì che noi abbiamo buona
memoria
delle ottime capacità di analisi dei
problemi e delle abilità sociali molto
sviluppate ecco le parole chiave secondo
me sono abilità sociali femminili
migliori io ho visto che i progetti
migliori sono frutto di gruppi di
progettazione dove donne e uomini sono
equamente rappresentati portano entrambi
il loro punto di vista perché questo fa
sì che nella progettazione
noi mettiamo e aggiungiamo le nostre
competenze tecniche quelle umane in
generale oggi un progetto non basta che
sia un progetto corretto deve essere un
progetto giusto un progetto corretto è
un progetto che rispetta i vincoli
strutturali le funzioni per cui
quell'opera deve essere progettata le
normative tecniche le norme di legge
un progetto giusto è tutto questo ma
mette al centro la società all'interno
della quale l'opera deve essere
realizzata progettando con umanità
questo vuol dire un grande sforzo una
cosa molto complessa imparare ad
ascoltare le persone i loro desideri le
loro esigenze
capire il territorio dove si va a
progettare e assecondare riuscirò a
prevedere gli impatti che l'opera avrà
nel territorio perché lo sviluppo di un
territorio dipende dall impatto sociale
che l'opera che tu stai progettando avrà
sul territorio stesso e sulle persone
pensate
faccio un esempio pensate se domani
costruissero una strada dietro a casa
vostra
che sensazioni avreste immagino vi
verrebbe in mente rumore traffico smog
probabilmente se vi venisse in mente un
colore sarebbe il grigio ecco in realtà
noi abbiamo progettato 30 km di una
strada in serra leone e la percezione è
stata completamente diversa
direi che una strada e sera leone venga
percepita in modo diametralmente opposto
intanto il titolo il titolo del progetto
è all seasons road una strada per tutte
le stagioni
una cosa che da noi in europa non ha un
gran senso ma una strada nuova in sierra
leone
deve riuscire sia sopportare il caldo
caldo torrido di alcuni mesi ma deve
soprattutto resistere nella stagione
delle piogge alle piogge stesse non deve
diventare un fiume quindi un limite
invalicabile una strada in sierra leone
è un centro di aggregazione sociale in
europa progettiamo strade nuove per
evitare le città per riuscire ad evitare
i centri urbani a sorpassarli ad
evitarli in sierra leone
se avessimo spostato il tracciato della
nuova strada rispetto alle strade
sterrate che nascono in modo naturale
i villaggi si sarebbero spostati con la
strada e un palo della luce un elemento
un oggetto con noi non facciamo nemmeno
più caso assume un'importanza
completamente diversa diventa un centro
di aggregazione per le persone che alla
sera in paesi dove l'elettricità non è
un bene alla portata di tutti si
raccolgono attorno al palo per riuscire
a raccontarsi storie per parlare per
ballare per giocare a volte
semplicemente per caricare cellulare in
modo abusivo
tutto questo è possibile e noi ci siamo
anche battuti su queste cose perché
per due motivi principalmente abbiamo
ascoltato i bisogni ei desideri delle
persone che lavoravano con noi e anche
che conoscevamo al di fuori dello
stretto orario di lavoro
secondo punto abbiamo costruito un team
di progettisti uomini e donne che
insieme si confrontavano non solo sulla
base delle loro capacità tecniche ma
soprattutto della loro esperienza umana
di quanto veniva loro in mente mangiando
qualche cosa la sera prima insieme ad
altri vedendo scene quotidiane dei
bambini che giocavano ai bordi di una
strada
ecco progettare in questo modo si può
dire che voglia dire progettare con
empatia per riuscire a progettare in
modo che le esigenze tecniche si
arricchiscano in qualche modo si
pieghino alle esigenze umane
bisogna mettersi nei panni degli altri
questo significa cercare di immaginare e
sognare come se noi fossimo uno di quei
bambini di quei ragazzi che gioca ai
bordi della strada
il punto di vista femminile è importante
proprio per questo perché aggiunge nei
gruppi di progetto aggiunge ai progetti
umanità comprensione e una pluralità di
vedute
purtroppo però il numero delle donne nel
settore dell'ingegneria e ancora troppo
basso non va oltre il 30 per cento ed
equilibrare il numero equilibrare la
presenza di uomini e donne è molto
importante per progettare meglio oscar
wilde diceva date alle donne occasioni
adeguate e saranno capaci di tutto
io faccio questo ogni giorno nel mio
lavoro cerco di portare le capacità
uniche delle donne all'interno di più
progetti possibili in questo modo sono
certa di avere progetti migliori e cerco
di dare occasioni alle ragazze ma tutto
questo non va
non basta cogliere le occasioni adeguate
le occasioni che ci vengono date
noi dobbiamo occupare più spazio
il nostro punto di vista non toglierà
mai spazio agli uomini perché il nostro
punto di vista arricchisce il prodotto
della progettazione per tutti gli uomini
e le donne
un progetto figlio del solo il 50 per
cento della metà dei rappresentanti
della nostra specie
non può essere un progetto completo
quindi progettare con umanità significa
questo esattamente punti di vista
diversi condivisi in un qualche modo
uniti a fattor comune per poter dare
risposte ai bisogni delle persone di
oggi e di domani
risposte che valgano oggi e domani per
tutto il genere umano
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]